well the cowboys did what they could to
one up the playoffs dropping during the
eagles playoff game the game the cowboys
would have been playing the news that
jason garrett is out dez bryant who
played for the cowboys for most of
garrett's tenure there tweeted i don't
have no sympathy for coach garrett
losing his job the cowboys just became
real contenders please dez tell us what
you really think so
it was a a strange process right the the
word that was out there all week was
that the cowboys are moving slowly when
it comes to jason garrett out of an
abundance of care and respect meanwhile
they started interviewing other guys
before they fired jason garrett marvin
the former bengals coach mike mccarthy
the former packers coach there was a
point where it was becoming
an embarrassment and it was good that
they did what they did when they did it
and i know that garrett wanted to stay
multiple reports indicating he was
trying to convince the cowboys to keep
him but at some point you can't just
start interviewing guys and comparing
them to garrett if you're going to
interview guys you got to get rid of the
guy you have you can't you can't do the
bird in the hand two in the bush thing
if you're moving on from garrett you
move on from garrett and they did
finally yeah they did and i mean i think
we all thought this was going on i think
we all thought that this was being done
the way it was being done because of the
respect the history for jason garrett
and i think the fact that they released
this news during the eagles playoff game
again i think shows you the respect
they're trying to give to jason garrett
almost like they didn't want to make it
a huge just one night story line where
all we talked about was jason garrett
being fired it's like okay yeah he got
fired we can move on and now who's the
head coach going to be there in dallas
and that's the million dollar question
is which way are they going to go here i
mean yes marvin lewis mccarthy being
interviewed are there college coaches on
the radar you know i've heard some
things there uh as far as three coaches
to look out for in the college ranks
lincoln riley dan mullen uh and matt
rule you know two of them are right down
the road from the dallas cowboys so
which way do the dallas cowboys go i
think is going to be the really
interesting thing here the next week dan
mullen of course was dak prescott's
coach when he was in college which
creates an obvious connection i i
you know jerry jones says things for
strategic reasons and three and a half
weeks ago he said that if you hire a
college coach you're putting yourself in
a learning curve and you're slowing down
your ability to be successful right and
maybe that's a diversion but maybe it is
a reflection of the the ever-present
reality that jerry jones wants to win
now
now now and even though his super bowls
came with a college coach jimmy johnson
yeah then later barry switzer i don't
know that they have the luxury to do
that i don't know either hey hey sean
payton's available
well yeah available now i mean yeah
they're not they're gonna have to trade
like yeah
i don't think it's gonna happen right
but if we thought it was gonna be my
zimmer available today but that's
definitely not available
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports